this is just me pointing out that the
real misogyny is having your wife sleep
with five men now Adam 22 loaned his
wife out to another man so he had his
wife of like 3 months do a porno with
another man right after they got married
so Len of the plug SLP with Jason love
and they did a a porno together and
really guys um I think this is an insult
to the institution of marriage I don't
understand why people like this get
married marriage is supposed to be a
religious institution I'm a Catholic and
in the Catholic church we believe it's
till death do you part for richer for
poor for sickness and in Hell till death
VI Part and people like this make a
mockery of the sacrament of marriage